這不是一幅普通的畫
這幅畫的材料是臺灣的歷史
我不是說畫裡畫了什麼
而是它的顏料
哎呦 抱歉
我又說錯了
這幅畫用的不是 「 顏料 」
而是一片一片來自臺灣的蝴蝶翅膀
你可能聽過
在半導體成為臺灣的代名詞之前
臺灣曾被稱作 「 蝴蝶王國 」
1960 年代
蝴蝶加工業進入黃金時期
埔里成了產業核心
數十家加工廠林立
每年出口量上億隻
外銷總值超過 3,000 萬美元
蝴蝶翅膀的色彩並不只是色素
而是光學結構色
翅上密集排列的鱗片
具有特殊多層奈米結構
能選擇性地反射特定波長的可見光
並讓光產生干涉與繞射
映出金屬般的亮藍 、 綠 、 紫這些顏色
這顏色不易褪去
特別適合長久保存的拼貼
直到 1980 年代之後
全球石油危機造成停滯性通膨
經濟衰退
全球景氣轉冷
再加上臺灣農業
以及旅宿的超限開發利用
蝴蝶數量劇烈下滑
蝴蝶加工外銷也逐漸式微
但這些美麗的蝴蝶
不只曾以生命撐起一門產業
它們更讓世界看見臺灣
還成為推動臺灣自然史學發展的關鍵
時隔一年
我再次走進科博館的蒐藏庫
我們要看看臺灣的生物資源有多豐富
自然史研究是怎麼開始的
又將如何前進
而這些精巧的標本
究竟為什麼對臺灣如此重要
我現在就在科博館的昆蟲蒐藏庫
其中就包含了臺灣的蝴蝶
為什麼蝴蝶是臺灣自然史的關鍵
國威
你這個問題問得非常好
Alfred Russel Wallace
就是華萊士跟摩爾 （ Frederic Moore ）
這兩個是倫敦自然史很著名的這一個
博物學家（ 與昆蟲學家 ）
然後那個時候
Robert Swinhoe 在臺灣擔任外交官的時候
他其實蒐集了大量的昆蟲的標本
那他把它寄回去歐洲英國以後呢
1866 年的時候
華萊士跟摩爾
以臺灣 （ 的昆蟲 ） 發表第一筆長篇的論文
發表在倫敦自然史的期刊裡面
然後裡面就提到有 46 種的蝴蝶
其中 5 種是新種哦
然後所以從 1866 年
它是一個很重要的時間點
從那個時候開始
世界開始注意到
原來臺灣有這麼多
非常珍奇的蝴蝶
帶動了整個蝴蝶的分類研究
等於是臺灣昆蟲學研究的火車頭了
那他很有名是因為他
很多動物都會以他的
冠上他的名字
對 斯文豪什麼什麼
很認真
對
那我們現在看到這兩箱
其實就是德國著名的
採集蒐藏學家 Hans Sauter （ 採集的 ）
那為什麼他重要呢
因為他留下大量的證據標本
變得是世界重要的一個引證的來源
所以即便在 100 年以後
我們還是仍然可以看到實體標本
然後去辨認它的身份
然後 Hans Sauter
他自己是在
茶葉的出口公司
叫德記洋行
那時候在臺南
他是一個 manager
他非常精通物流
所以透過這樣的一個物流經驗
其實他在臺灣建立了一個很重要的網絡
從北到南
包含臺東
總共建立了 45 個採集點
然後他非常有系統的在採集
這件就是我們算是非常早的標本
也是 Hans Sauter 採集的
那這個其實已經滅絕了
它是臺灣的大紫斑蝶
那你可以從這個 Hans Sauter
他自己親筆手寫的標籤上面
可以看到 Taihanroku
Formosa
Hans Sauter
然後八月是羅馬字 Ⅷ 月
然後 08 年是 1908 年採集的
那 Taihanroku 在哪裡呢
就是現在的墾丁的南灣地區
那你可以知道
現在墾丁南灣沙灘跟水上活動
一個非常頻繁的地方
可是在 100 多年前
Hans Sauter 在那邊採集的時候
是一片 （ 類 ）紅樹植物 （ 海檬果 ）
那它們訪花會在那裡
然後吃東西也在那裡
可是現在那邊已經都沒有了
所以 Hans Sauter 的這個證據標本
它可以幫我們勾勒出
100 多年前
這種蝴蝶如果是在那邊被採集到
那它的環境會長什麼樣子
就活生生的證據
對 那你可以看到
這些蝴蝶其實已經都滅絕了
那這是其中一種
大紫斑蝶
那像這個的話呢
這上面寫 Amping （ 安平 ）
對耶
然後 1909 年 ...
... 6 月
歹勢
老花了
我這也很難
看不出
因為 Hans Sauter 標籤很小
那越小越好
因為這是在自然史博物館裡面
你會看到的
一個很重要的一個特徵之一
標籤不能比蟲子大
因為會佔掉太多的空間
所以那個時候都是用非常小的 （ 標籤 ）
而且那個時候
100 年前
用打字機打印出來的
這一個墨水
是在這個紙板上面是黏得很牢的
完全沒有褪色
它沒有褪色
那這個也是很重要的一個指標
就是我們要非常確定
我們今天打印的標籤
能夠在 100 年 、 200 年
還可以被後人看到
它是在哪邊採集的
那這一件就是紅腹七星美盾蝽
那它現在已經確定 （ 在臺灣 ） 是滅絕了
就是我們已經找不到了
所以這是曾經
現在都破碎了
活生生的證據
對
去年的時候我去菲律賓做調查的時候
直接現場看到
紅腹七星美盾蝽活著時候的樣子
然後也知道
確定它的寄主也跟臺灣一樣
因為它們是同一種的
它是一個很重要的指標
因為它都生活在
跟人類非常
幾乎是重疊的環境
那為什麼國外沒有滅絕
那臺灣的滅絕了
值得深思
可以好好想的一個問題
哇 這些都 100 多年前的標本
而且上面就標著 Ｆormosa
這大概是很多外國人認識臺灣的開始吧
沒錯
就是 Hans Sauter 那個時候
在臺灣採集的這些大量的昆蟲標本
那以這個 Formosa 的採集品
這些歐洲的這些學者
總共發表了超過 400 篇的學術文章
哦
然後超過 2,300 多種的模式標本
所以當時國際上真的把臺灣當成一個
這個新種發現的寶庫
昆蟲的寶庫
沒錯就是那個時候
如果我們以臺灣的蝴蝶的物種為例的話
臺灣蝴蝶大概將近 400 種
那日本也只有 250 種
那如果以國土面積來看的話
臺灣平均每 1 萬平方公里有 110 種的蝴蝶
日本呢
每 1 萬平方公里只有 6.6 種的蝴蝶
那我們壓倒性的勝利
對 所以日本人那個時候才發現說
哇
臺灣這個蝴蝶王國不是被叫假的
臺灣的蝴蝶多樣性之高
著名的博物學家鹿野忠雄
1927 - 1932 年間
在臺灣進行大量昆蟲採集與研究
尤其是甲蟲
鹿野也是第一位發現
臺灣冰河地形 、 櫻花鉤吻鮭的人
還評論臺灣的生物地理
修正了華萊士線
從印尼蘇拉維西與菲律賓之間
往北延伸至臺灣與蘭嶼之間
白水隆
則是日本九州大學的鱗翅學專家
一生都專注蝴蝶分類與生物地理
1960 年他出版 《 原色臺灣蝶類大圖鑑 》
系統性的整理自 1866 年華萊士等人開始
到 1960 年約百年的臺灣蝴蝶文獻
被視為臺灣蝶類研究的里程碑
與長期使用的工具書
我們的主要標本
有八成左右是自己採集的
然後大概有兩成左右
就是受這些昆蟲學家的捐贈
那其中就是剛剛沼田康夫
他是日本的一個
業餘的愛好者
他自己也有發表一些
蛾類的一些新種
那他很慷慨的
就是捐贈了科博館 25,000 隻的 （ 標本 ）
25,000 隻
對 而且是來自於世界各地
主要以東南亞為主
在那個南美洲的一些標本
像貓頭鷹蝶啊
然後那個大藍閃蝶 Morpho
所以他就自己花了很多時間
自己親自採集
然後親自一隻一隻把標本做好
哇 那有那麼多的這個昆蟲標本
你到底要怎麼管理啊
我們大概有 172 萬件標本
然後 6 成左右
超過 100 萬件是昆蟲
正確的做法很重要
然後還有標籤上面的這一些時地物
什麼時候被採集的
然後是誰採集的
然後在哪個地方採集
甚至有座標的資訊在這一個標籤上面
所以連這張紙都要考究
連它的材質
還有它的墨都要考究
因為連那張紙都要能夠活過 100 年
所以即便你最後有一隻標本了
可是標籤沒了
我們還是沒有辦法去考證說
這隻蟲子的來源在哪裡
好 國威
那我等下就會開始帶著你去做
怎麼樣子的做法
才是符合博物館的
這樣的標準製作方式
那標本製作方式有四種
第一種就是昆蟲針直接插穿過蟲體
然後這是我們講的
最標準的針插標本的做法
嗯
如果這個蟲子呢
比較小
我們就用台紙的做法
台紙的做法
就是我們會選擇適當的 size
然後黏在這個台紙上面
嗯
一體化
對
如果再更小的話呢
就是像這種三角籤的
就是它有一個頂點
它有一個最尖端的
然後把這一個蟲子很精準的黏在這個
這個部位
那另外一種叫做二針法
就是你可以看到這邊除了一根針以外
昆蟲針
這邊還有一根小針
哇塞
我們叫微針
這也太細了吧
對 而且這個還需要做到展翅以後
然後用二針的方式來做一個處理
我現在講話我都怕吹到它
對
怕把它翅膀吹壞
我現在拿的時候也覺得有點抖
所以你可以看到
標準針插法 、 黏貼法
二針法 、 展翅法
這幾種
所以昆蟲的種類很多
所以我們一定要選擇一個最合適
最正確的方式去做它
那我今天要來挑戰的是什麼呢
材料就在你眼前了
就在這裡
對
哦哦哦
選一個你想要
哇
這裡面有好多甲蟲
然後有大有小
嗯 對
你選一個
因為它們看起來好像還活著
讓我覺得我不知道該怎麼辦
哈哈哈
這一隻是刺緣大薄翅天牛
你可以看到 天牛嘛
天牛的特徵就是它觸角特別長
有九節
像呂布一樣
對 像呂布一樣有九節
就是有九個分節
哦
然後剩下就是甲蟲的樣子
然後 哎呦
你看它勾到我了
小心
我們就把它放在這裡
好
然後呢
這邊就是我們會用到的工具
我們有鑷子 、 有白膠
然後有 1 號
2 、 3 、 4 、 5 號
五個號碼的針
數字越小越細
數字越大越粗
第一個就是先挑戰大的
那我的建議就是從 4 號針
就是我們就用 4 號針
大針
對 用大針
所以我要用手下還是用拿鑷子下
我們都是像這這麼大的話
我們用手下就好了
OK 好
來這邊有一個對照給你
這邊有天牛的做法
好 那你就看他怎麼做
特徵比較少的地方
特徵比較少的地方大概就在這裡
這也是
下針的話呢
要直直的
什麼叫直直的
下去的時候是直的
跟身體垂直
嗯嗯
然後呢
這樣也跟身體垂直
嗯嗯嗯
所以如果它你這個角度跟這個角度
你發現它是歪的
那就代表...
我毀了它
你沒有到毀了它
就是
沒有那麼的...
就是就是需要
好
不用委婉了不用委婉了
我毀了它
就這樣 好 OK
好
腳的話
我們通常就是讓腳都先往外擴
OK
因為你等下還要展足嘛
對對對
所以我們大家一開始的時候
我們通常都是先把腳都先攤開
OK 那趴好
對 趴好
觸角也都
確定每個地方都是鬆的
關節地方鬆的
那這個時候你就可以下針了
那我在旁邊好看著你做
好
如果我做錯就拿針插我
哈哈哈
那我可能選 5 號吧
先不要 哈哈哈
我覺得光移動它就很困難
因為有些關節它只能在某個方向移動
我們在做標本的時候也要非常瞭解它的結構
對對對
不然你很容易把它掰斷
好 那我現在就是固定它
（ 嘆 ）
下針
這很難哎
第一次接觸的時候
它要稍微用一點力才能夠刺穿
它的翅鞘
有了 進去了
對 然後你就開始慢慢的垂直下去
哎 糟糕
我沒有辦法判斷它是不是歪的
你就是直直地下去
哦 OK
好
這應該出來
對 有有有
看到針了
哦 OK
對
然後這個時候你就看說你有沒有插直
就是從
有點歪
這樣可以
這樣可以接受
OK
perfect
這時候就是再把放
放回到這個展臺上
這個泡棉臺上
OK
好
好 等下
這邊有一個平均臺
來 1 、 2 、 3 、 4 、 5 階
嗯
我們昆蟲
其實一根昆蟲針插到就是任何的標本
除了標本本身以外
下面不是會有一堆標籤嗎
嗯嗯嗯
那一堆標籤
為什麼它可以插的這麼的平整
都是靠平均臺
所以越淺的
越淺的是留給蟲子的
越深的是留給標籤的
嗯
我們這邊要留大概一公分
或是 8 毫米的高度
嗯嗯嗯
因為你這樣手會比較好拿
好
那我現在不用固定它
對 你不用固定它
因為你已經刺穿它了
然後把它壓去
好
你這個就是我們最後要的高度
這就我們要的高度
差不多
好 然後再把拿回來
一樣
那這個時候我們就要開始
去固定它的腳
所有的博物館
它的空間有限
對
所以通常都是做得越緊實越好
嗯
所以我們的腳
跟觸角都會收在身體的兩側
然後第一個就是省空間
第二個是
如果它能夠保存到 100 年以上
你如果收得越確實
下一個人再拿的時候
比較不會碰斷它的腳
嗯嗯
因為它腳已經被你縮在身體兩側了
大家都是怎麼選
選順手的
選順手的就好了
好示範一下
我就會把它靠攏
這樣就靠攏 就是靠攏
然後靠攏以後
你就會拿針去開始固定它
把它
然後再來就是再靠攏
讓它腳不要開太多
然後最後這個收回來
收回來這樣子
嗯哼
然後右邊做完然後做左邊
然後因為它勾到了
所以我們稍微提一下
對 然後
你需要再拿一根固定針
好
雖然它都是靠攏的
可是還是有所謂的對稱感
對稱性
哈哈哈
我知道你的意思它並不對稱
我從這裡開始
對對對
就是這樣子
這到底要用壞多少隻標本
才有辦法
對稱許多了
對 差不多了
通常會插那麼多根嗎
如果很會做的人他會插很少根
我瞭解你的意思
哈哈哈
哎 OK
好 然後這時候就問一下觀眾
這樣有沒有對稱
所以做法就是縮足
所以下一個階段呢
就是打籤
所以這個叫無酸紙
對 這個 Acid free
就是它是沒有酸性物質在裡面
所以它不會因為時間的關係
或是我們叫中性紙也可以
無酸中性紙
確定都打印好以後
接著就是上我們科博館的身份證
它會是一個條碼
我們就會拿到 40 ℃ 的循環式烘箱
因為有水分的話
你如果都不做任何處理的話
它就會開始發臭了
然後一個禮拜左右的時間
就會很乾了
嗯
未來我們還是可以抽它的
這個肌肉的組織
還是可以抽的到高品質的 DNA
哦 那烘乾之後它就長這樣嗎
我可以把針拆掉
對 烘乾完以後
我們就下一個階段就拔針了
然後那個標籤你都打好了
嗯
所以你就可以開始把這隻天牛
（ 記錄 ）它所有的被採集資訊
如果是這樣的標 （ 籤 ）
這樣的一個 size 的話
填到我們的標本箱
它至少可以放 500 隻
嗯
對 所以它其實是一個非常省空間的做法
博物館寸土寸金
嗯
只好委屈各位了
我們剛剛做完標本
然後這個標籤也都上了
下一個階段就是把這一個標本呢
從目開始分
因為界門綱目的目
比如說昆蟲綱
然後如果是有蝴蝶的話就是鱗翅目
那如果你覺得它看起來像甲蟲
就是鞘翅目
如果覺得它看起來像蟬
它就是半翅目
它如果像蜜蜂的話就是膜翅目
你就把它想像成
你小時候對昆蟲的記憶
計時開始
為什麼覺得有陷阱
好 我分類完了
請揭曉答案
我們先從這盒開始看
那這盒國威分的不錯
因為大部分都是椿象
但只有這隻不是椿象
這隻是吉丁蟲
哦
吉丁蟲
它是屬於甲蟲
就是鞘翅目的
然後我們就把這一隻吉丁蟲放進去
像這一隻也是甲蟲
這隻是金花蟲
嗯
那我們就把它再放到這邊來
那接著呢
我們就是以這個椿象來看好了
因為這個是你分的最完整的
長得都很不一樣
但是你都把它分成功了
還有沒有椿象
好
那像這一隻是水黽
水黽也是椿象的一種
水黽也是椿象
椿象有分陸生 、 半水生跟水生的
這隻也是椿象哦
這隻就是完全水生的
這是它的呼吸管
這叫紅娘華
有有 有聽過
這一隻也是椿象
蛤
這一隻是蚊獵蝽
哦 長得像蚊子的獵蝽
然後這一隻也是椿象
怎麼那麼多椿象
不好意思 我特別喜歡椿象
然後這隻也是椿象啊
它還是椿象
對
這隻也是椿象
等一下等一下
哈哈哈
整我
大概就正確答案
就長這個樣子
哦
那之後就要分科了
但不是這一集
再分科
那麼多的標本裡面
哪些標本最有價值啊
哦 這個問得好
那我的回答一定是模式標本
這邊是我們模式標本區
模式標本的意思
就是生物的名字跟實體標本綁在一起
就是每個生物都有自己的名字
昆蟲分類學家當他描述新種的時候
他就會把這名字跟實體標本
永久的綁在一起
然後那個標本
就是帶有名字身份的一個
重要的證據標本
我們就稱它為是一個模式標本
那全世界就這一組啊
如果有其他外國學者想要來比對的話
他得買機票
直接飛來
就得來科博館
就來這邊看
那這邊的模式標本
我們可以看到比如說
就是有一些有顏色的標
標籤很豐富
然後標籤上面就會是寫說 types
那他可能會寫 holotype 或 paratype
就是正模式標本跟副模式標本
昆蟲分類學家
在做一個物種描述的時候
因為昆蟲種類實在太多了
所以兩個看起來很像的
我們怎麼樣子辨認
它是不一樣的
有時候都就非常仰賴生殖器
那生殖器的話
通常是雄性的生殖器
特徵會比較多
所以
我們就會把它的那個生殖器
給解剖下來
然後放在寶貝罐裡面
哎哎
這邊真的還有個罐子
對 就是叫寶貝罐
我們叫它 Genitalia Vial
就是專門裝生殖器的罐子
可是我們可以通俗的講
它就是寶貝罐
模式標本的重點就在寶貝罐啊
對
就是它解剖下來的這個特徵
是鑑種的特徵
那當然
還有不是寶貝罐的方式
因為昆蟲種類太多了
我們還有
做成玻片的
比如說像蛾類的標本
哇
那你可以看到
就是蛾類的腹部比較比較肥厚
所以它就直接做成是玻片
就是你可以看
它這個腹部都被被解剖下來了
那蛾類的解剖方式
你也是必須要把整個腹部摘掉以後
然後去做一個透化
做一個解剖的處理
然後最後要用這個永久封片的方式
把它封存起來
這是蛾類在做這個
命名描述的時候
他們最常會使用到的一種處理方式
針對它們的
生殖器官
這第一次看到
對
然後另外一種呢
就是...
噢
然後再來呢
就是我可以把它的
哇
我可以把它的生殖器黏在板子上
你可以看
這個是昆蟲
然後上面是它的那個...
雞雞
生殖器
對
這個...
嗯
這個比大小感覺
那被切出來才會知道誰比較大
誰比較小
這個也太迷你了...
那像這樣的模式標本
科博館有多少
我們現在有 5,000 多件的模式標本
算是全臺灣自然史博物館裡面
模式標本最多的地方
我們就這樣放在這邊嗎
為什麼要特別放在這邊
哦對
國威的觀察非常的細膩
我們把模式標本都集中放在這一區了
第一個比較好檢視
就是說如果國外的人來了
他如果只想看模式標本
全部都在這裡
所以他找會很方便
嗯
畢竟有那麼多昆蟲物種嘛
再來你有沒有發現
它離這個我們的安全門很近
因為萬一
萬一真的科博館發生火災
又在這間庫房
那這些就是我們最重要要搶救的資產
哈哈哈
就是全部
就是要離門近一點
無懸念的
就是一就是把
把它推出去就對
然後離我們的逃生入口是最近的
所以你就可以瞭解模式標本的重要性
因為幾年前的巴西的一間博物館
它發生大火
所有的模式都標本都燒光光
有些是恐龍化石的正模
有些是
南美洲
北美洲第一個人骨化石也被燒掉
嗯 對
所以燒掉就不可能再找到了
哦
或是很難再重現了
是
國際生物命名規約上
在發表一個新種時
研究者會從一批採集到的標本中
指定其中特徵表現最清楚的唯一一件
作為正模式標本
它就像這個物種名字的本尊
名字 、 描述 、 產地與形態特徵
都以它為最後的比對基準
日後如果有人想做物種比對
想知道自己有沒有發現新物種
科學界都要回到這一件來核對
正模式通常蒐藏在公立博物館
如果不是
自己國家的物種
通常也會送還給對方的博物館
而同一批裡
沒有被指定為正模的其它個體
稱為副模式標本
它們呈現族群的自然變異
公母 、 大小 、 季節型
不同採集點的差異
副模式標本
也可以提供國外其他博物館或機構
作為研究比對使用
或是在正模式標本損毀或遺失時
作為備份
但說到標本
除了昆蟲針插標本
還有我們上次來科博館時
介紹過的立姿標本
棍棒標本
還有一種我們還沒介紹過
那就是浸液標本
阿磐老師
為什麼我們要把這些物種
做成浸液標本
因為有時候比如說一個動物
它有羽毛
你不可能泡在液體裡面
那如果說是它有外骨骼
那它外骨骼
可以有一個蠻好的保存的形態
但是以兩棲或爬蟲或者是魚類來講
它就沒有辦法有外骨骼
或者是它也沒有羽毛
它重要的表面是鱗片
所以這個時候用浸液標本
就是一個蠻好的處置方法
它只要經年去把酒精維持乾淨和補充
不需要那麼嚴格的環境
像別的蒐藏庫
他們有很嚴格的溫濕度
在這裡就沒有那麼需要了
而且它裡面外面都可以保存的到
我們只是要看外表
沒有問題
我們要看到身體裡面
還是沒有問題
甚至它體表上的一些寄生蟲
也還是有機會可以再從標本中取得
浸液標本的顏色沒那麼鮮艷
但我們最想保留的不是外觀
而是能被反復驗證的資訊
兩生爬蟲的關鍵特徵
常常在皮下與體內
舌骨 、 腺體 、 骨突 、 鱗片排列與皮褶
甚至雄性生殖構造
經過福馬林固定
再泡入 70% 的酒精
這些形態能穩定保留
之後
用組織切片或微斷層掃描
都看得出差異
就是我們在固定浸液標本的時候
我們有兩種溶液可以選擇
一種可能是浸泡在福馬林裡頭
一種是浸泡在酒精裡頭
那浸泡在酒精裡面是比較安全
然後也比較經濟的方法
畢竟福馬林是毒的東西
酒精沒有這個問題
但是酒精有個缺點呢
就是它會讓顏色失真
它特別容易把一些綠綠藍藍的東西
溶出來
但是顏色的變化往往是比較不穩定的
對生物來講
無論是動植物都是如此
所以在看
浸泡在酒精裡的浸液標本的時候
通常會先
假定這個顏色是已經是不準了
它已經不再是原本的顏色了
但是我們要看內在
看內在以及看它的形態
也就是距離多長啊
比例上啊 這些形態
生殖孔洞啊這些
或者是一些斑點
應該都還是沒有問題
你看這兩罐有不一樣的地方嗎
呃
我現在只看得到一罐大罐一罐小罐
這是很好的觀察
呵呵呵
這裡有兩種不同的青蛙
它們都是赤蛙
但是它們不一樣哦
咦
這小罐裡面出來的比較大
大罐裡面出來的比較小哦
那我們可以看到左邊這一隻
顏色比較深
顏色比較淺
不過我們現在
先不管顏色了
我們先看看它的吻部是否有不一樣
吻部是嘴巴這邊嗎
對 您看看這個吻部的感覺
用感覺的
這樣子的
突突的感覺跟這個突突的感覺
您覺得哪一個比較突呢
不是 如果你沒這樣問我
我就覺得它們根本一模一樣
哦 那分類學家比較斤斤計較
我們會說
這個吻部的突出來的程度
它比較尖嘛
如果要說的話的確是
當然
報導的時候確實會有一些量化的過程
不過我們感覺起來這個比較突一些
這個比較扁平一些
另外再看它的後腿的小腿骨
這一段
您覺得比例上
哦好
您覺得它哪個比較長一些
蛤
這很難判斷
這個到底要跟它自己的大腿比嗎
還是
對 用比例
這個它比較長一點
對
這個好像
所以這就是兩種長得很像的赤蛙
但是它們因為這些微小的特徵
就可以區別出
對於分類學家
他們就可以區別出長得不一樣
那這個叫長腳赤蛙
這個是梭德赤蛙
分類學家都外貌協會就對了
所以它們顏色的差異
其實就完全無關
因為已經泡在酒精裡面
對對對 沒錯
假如有一個分類學家
或者是有生態學家
他想要去考察過去的蛙
或者是某個地點的蛙
他在博物館找到這些標本
嗯
他還是可以測量這些形態上的特徵
非常的容易哦
或者是要去看它
它的生殖的孔道啊
或者是它要在解剖裡面的腸道的狀態
哦
浸液標本都還
能夠提供原本的這些特徵
不知道你想不想試看看
從冰箱拿出來的屍體
變成這麼漂亮的標本
好
我們來挑戰看看
OK
我們現在戴了保護雙手的東西
首先我們要先幫它辨識身份
幫它掛上個名牌
首先我們這裡有一個
這是一隻雨傘節
這裡有一張標籤紙
這個不是一般的紙張
不是木頭纖維做的
它其實是塑膠
哦 是塑膠
另外
再尋常不過的鉛筆
這個標籤投到酒精浸液裡頭
還要保存著好幾百年
我們還希望它可以被閱讀
有好多個細節可以記
但是至少要記三件事
就是時間 、 地點 、 採集者
感覺不太一樣對不對
寫起來不太一樣
OK 地點是馬祖南竿
嗯
好 那這裡採集者
我只唸出丁某某就好
你就寫一下
請您把它綁在頸部這附近即可
哎呀這個
我是這個要綁我就怕
綁緊即可
好
OK
非常的好
就是這樣子
OK
所以在浸液標本室的每一隻個體
它一定都要有一張這個
才是合格的
所以我們需要先用福馬林做固定
我們會拿針筒
注射一些稀釋過的福馬林
注射到體內
那固定完成以後
我們會再把它泡到酒精裡
就大功告成了
好
對
你如果是注射的完整的話
待會調那個姿勢的時候
它就比較不會浮上來
好不錯
不錯不錯
哦
好
把福馬林倒進去
然後經過一個禮拜的時間
固定完以後
我們就會把它拿到那個水龍頭裡面
把它沖掉
然後換成酒精保存液
大概是這樣
這個固定了一個禮拜之後
它就變成一根彈簧了
原本的標籤綁在身上
那個還在
但是會有一個更正式的標籤
像這邊
這是一個叫布氏樹蛙
樹蛙
那麼您看到外面有一個很大的標籤
記得所有的細節
電腦打字的印刷呢
它是不能用
噴墨印表機或雷射印表機
它也弄不上去
因為它是不同的材料做的
它要用那種最傳統的
點陣式
對 噠噠噠
那一種
剛剛我們聊到了
固定完之後
福馬林固定完了以後
保存的會很好
但是福馬林有一個致命缺點
就是它會損失
它會把 DNA 切的亂七八糟
所以
就再也不能做遺傳學有關的研究了
因為 DNA 等於壞掉
那為了要保留原始的遺傳學資訊
在固定之前先取出一段組織
通常會是肌肉比較豐富的位置
然後也不是重要的特徵的位置
然後把它預先泡在高濃度酒精
可能是 95% 的酒精裡頭哦
想要看形態或者是體表狀態的
可以看原始的標本
想要抽取 DNA 做遺傳學分析的話
也有一份
就那一罐
對
那阿磐老師
我後面那麼多的標本裡面
有模式標本嗎
有 你想看看嗎
這一些模式標本
是博物館最重要的資產
它都被我們鎖在一個保險庫裡頭
對
所以今天特別拿出來讓你們看看
浸液標本有一種特別的展示方法
就是拿一個玻璃片
然後拿棉繩
把它用原始的姿態綁在玻璃片上
有利於展示給觀眾欣賞
所以這是一種浸液標本的展示方式
我還以為它裂掉了
原來是一個玻璃片
哎對
它就是一個玻璃片
然後用棉繩把它綁好
然後綁的時候
我們會關注它原始的生活的姿態
盡量復原它原本的姿態來擺
我們還有一些
像是呂氏攀蜥
我剛剛說的呂氏攀蜥
林氏禽蛙
這邊還有一個漢氏草蜥
那個第一個字是什麼意思
你猜猜看
當初命名的科學家嗎
雖然有可能是
但是剛好這幾件更有意涵哦
科學家在發表新的物種的時候
對 發表的人有權對它命名
常見的命名方式會是它的重要特徵
它獨特之處
比如說它黑黑的
或者是它尖尖的
諸如此類的
那有的甚至就用自己的名字命名
像今天我們講到好多斯文豪氏
那另外一種呢
科學家是以他認為
對於科學有重大貢獻的人
作為命名
哦
呂光洋教授
算是臺灣的兩棲爬蟲學界的
第一代臺灣自己人
哦
他發表了很多新的物種和紀錄種
那呂氏攀蜥就是以他的名字作為命名
那另外這個是漢氏草蜥
但是漢氏草蜥 所謂的漢呢
紀念的是第一任科博館
第一任館長漢寶德先生
哦
原來如此
對 因為漢寶德先生對於這個
當初去國外做這個採集
以及建設這些那個蒐藏庫
很努力的找了很多經費
然後也非常認同
臺灣應該有一個很好的自然史博物館
所以他除了把展場做好之外
他有很大的投資
都是投資在要撐 100 年
200 年的這種概念的蒐藏庫之下
所以幫它冠了一個名字
彰顯他的貢獻
阿磐老師
我還有另外一個問題
為什麼有些罐子裡面像這樣裝那麼多
那這個罐子就還好
那有的呢
就只裝一隻
我們先瞭解到
它們裝在一起是有一些緣由的
它一定是同一個物種 、 同樣的人
在同一個地方
同一個時間一起採集來的
我把它放在一起
就代表了一個重要的訊息
就是
它是同一個時空之下的同一個物種
生物學概念中的族群
在同一個時間之下
可能得到的證據
與需要清除內臟的剝製標本不同
浸液標本能讓我們打開胃腸道
檢視胃內容物與內外寄生蟲
最關鍵的是時空序列
當年這裡的溫度 、 雨季 、 獵物 、 寄生壓力
通通被錨定在時間座標上
多年後回頭比對
你才能看見物種遭遇了哪些環境壓力
又做出了哪些改變
如果還有謎團
那就再把問題泡進時間裡
等著下一個研究者把答案撈起來
最近比較有趣的故事就是有科學家呢
他針對兩棲
蜥蜴類和蛇類的身上的外寄生蟲
做研究
那他就是努力的
在這個地方工作了好幾個禮拜
一直去把這些蜥蜴和蛇
他覺得可疑的全部
一隻一隻的仔細檢視
一隻一隻拿出來仔細檢視
就這些
像是這樣的標本
然後他就發現了
在這些標本之中
他不是只有 （ 檢視 ） 一種種類哦
他不是只針對某一種蜥蜴或某一種蛇
他是廣泛地去搜尋
他發現某一種
外寄生蟲
是一種 tick（ 蜱類 ； 屬蛛形綱 ）
他發現過去
大家認為它 （ 寄生蟲 ） 應該是主要在蛇身上
結果他發現同樣的這種 tick
也會在蠻多蜥蜴身上
像是最常見的攀木蜥蜴
或者是原生種的長尾真稜蜥
或者是赤尾青竹絲
哦
雖然它看不到是那個綠色的了
因為顏色變了
但是他發現在那一種外寄生蟲
也會在這種不同的兩棲爬蟲身上
也可以找得到
就連我們當初也不知道
它上面有寄生蟲啊
但是有做寄生蟲的人告訴我們
這個寄生蟲
過去認為
它不應該寄生在這些動物身上
我們在你這裡找到蠻多的
於是就變成新的科學知識
那另外一個有趣的例子是
我們在這裡總共有
蒐藏了臺灣的 1,000 多件的蛇類的標本
那蛇類的標本
我們可以做一個整體性的研究
就是我們針對蛇的眼睛
測量它的眼睛大小
像是從最原始的這種叫做盲蛇
盲是那個眼睛失明的盲
嗯
它是一種穴居長得像蚯蚓一樣
穴居型的蛇
我有一次挖到一隻盲蛇
我以為是蚯蚓呢
結果它吐信了
哈哈哈 我就
這是蛇
那像這隻是海蛇
那麼還有這個是很常見的
比較中大型的
這個臭青公
然後再來這個是很凶的過山刀
那我們就針對每一種蛇
所有我們館內所有的蛇的眼睛
做了測量
還有同時也測量它的頭的大小
在這個蛇眼
從很原始的盲蛇
一直演化到各種不同棲位
不同生活方式
不同分類群的蛇類中
它們眼睛的大小有沒有
有沒有受到什麼演化上的適應
那眼睛是變大呢
還是變小呢
我們關心這個問題
那它是什麼樣的生活方式
會改變它眼睛大小的趨勢呢
所以就做了這個統合性的
巨大演化的研究
您看看
這一隻過山刀眼睛夠大吧
有
都不用再去外科整容了
水汪汪的
對
那您看這個盲蛇
這應該是完全看不到
根本看不到眼睛在哪裡
嗯 對
事實上它眼睛就只有一個小小的孔
它是穴居型的
就像蚯蚓一樣的生活環境
它根本不需要用眼睛
因此我們整體發現是日行性的
樹棲性的
眼睛比較大
最大顆
然後海蛇夜行性的就比較小
也許有一天
這一些東西就再也不會存在
未來的孩子們
要再看到這個地方的這些標本
他也只能再從博物館來看到
並且學到一些我們該怎麼跟這個社會
跟這個世界共處的一些知識
我認為這個也是很有價值的
的確
2026 年就是科博館的 40 周年
科博館裡的每一件標本
不論是針插 、 立姿 、 棍棒或浸液
都把名字 、 地點 、 時間牢牢綁在一起
而這些蒐藏
都是為未來研究
保留重要的基礎或證據
標本留下的是記錄與歷史
同時把這些資料留給未來
每一個標本都是由人手親自處理
是臺灣自然史最可靠的記憶體
哪一種標本最讓你驚訝
再留言告訴我們吧
想看我們再開哪個蒐藏庫房
也等你點名
更重要的是
如果你也感動了
下次有相關的展覽
就來科博館親自見見它們吧
如果看不過癮
精選典藏網上也有許多館藏
能讓你從不同角度欣賞館藏
或是看到那些之前我們介紹過
但無法展出的展品
也別忘記訂閱泛科學
開啟小鈴鐺
我們下次再見